here in the US a funeral was held today  for one of the two Virginia State  Troopers killed last weekend in the  Charlottesville helicopter crash Burke  Bates had been assigned to record aerial  footage of the white supremacist rally  that erupted in violence the married  father of two died the day before his  41st birthday officials are  investigating whether the chopper had a  mechanical problem also today the mayor  of Charlottesville called for an  emergency session of Virginia's  legislature to allow the city to remove  a statue of Confederate General Robert E  Lee plans to scrap the monument drew  white supremacists from across the  country